- Anybody who eats an
Oreo all together, though,
is a monster.
(upbeat music)
- I guess the question is who
doesn't love Oreo cookies?
- They're the best cookie.
- I've only seen a picture of it.
It does have, like, Oreo in the
middle covered in chocolate.
- I hope it's big and I
hope that it crunches.
- I don't know what Milka chocolate is.
- I've never heard of it.
- It's the purple bars,
I think they're European.
- It's a little more high end.
- Wow!
- Dude!
- Oh my God.
- Jesus Christ.
- This is enormous.
Is this for one person?
- This is, like, family size.
This is an Oreo cookie
palette, like a plate.
- That's some good ass chocolate.
- Mmm.
- M-Hm.
- Where are you taking that?
- I figured you were done.
- This tastes like
- Sh, just have a minute.
- Okay, yeah, we'll just
have a sec to enjoy.
- It's creamy, you got
the crunch in the middle.
- It's like a really
soft, milky chocolate.
- The first bite I took
actually hurt a tooth back here.
- Why don't they sell Oreo cream in jars?
- Oh, what, no.
- This is a lot for me, this is very rich.
- You know the food is good
when you sing a little tune.
- Or you, like, do a little movement.
- Mm-Hm.
- That's a lot.
That's a lot.
- It's not.
- Get this in a stocking.
- Seven servings?
Please, what, for ants?
- This exceeded my expectations by 110%.
- Oreo, you done good.
- [Woman In Hat] I liked
to dip cookies in tea.
- [Brunette Woman] Okay, cut that.